une laveuse qui commande elle même du
détergent une imprimante qui s'occupe
d'acheter toutes seules de nouvelles
cartouches d'encre c'est devenu une
réalité aux états unis avec le nouveau
service d'achat lancée hier par le géant
la distribution amazon bon sens mathieu
en sorcellerie est un service qui
soulève un bien les questions comment ça
fonctionne la mer bon ça s'appelle dash
double poney chemine donc s'est offert
aux clients qui ont le service amazon
prime aux états unis comme ça peut
fonctionner par exemple avec des
laveuses à linge comme celles qui ont
été lancés lors du ces et es à las vegas
les deux semaines donc une laveuse dans
lequel on met tous notre détergent
liquide dès qu'ils étaient que plus
équipés de senseurs et qui va commander
elle-même une nouvelle bouteille de
détergents quand elle se rend compte que
on arrive elle arrive là au bout de son
de son réservoir peut se demander si on
a vraiment besoin 8 me pose la même
chose à propos des notifications
facebook y ait dix ans alors ça
s'inscrit quand même dans une tendance
clip tout à fait global soit
effectivement c'est l'internet des
objets qu'est ce que c'est l'internet
des objets mais imaginez-vous le que de
plus en plus des objets qui nous
entourent sont connectés eux mêmes à
internet
les moteurs d'avions les moteurs
d'avions les automobiles on a aussi les
caméras de surveillance qu'on a chez
nous pour surveiller les enfants
on a évidemment les laveuses à linge les
imprimantes et aussi les calculateurs de
taux de glucose qui font partie des
trois produits de lancement de ce
service amazon dash replacement
bon évidemment est ce qu'il ya des
risques à laisser entrer comme ça
l'internet des objets c'est toute la
question parce que vous savez l'internet
des objets depuis 2012 selon cisco le
nombre d'objets connectés sur internet a
dépassé le nombre d'êtres humains sur la
planète à la fin 2012 on était à 8
points 7 milliards d'objets connectés
2014 17 milliards d'objets connectés et
on prévoit d'ici cinq ans qui en or 75
milliards d'objets connectés
alors si 75 milliards de portes ouvertes
aux pirates
alors est ce qu'on est prêt à connecter
notre maison complet pour se faire
pirater notre maison moment donné parce
que le une laveuse on peut penser que
c'est un peu banal mais quand c'est le
système de chauffage
c'est une autre paire de manches et
évidemment
le service amazon dash vous venez à
peut-être dans quelques années avec un
système amazon prime qu'est ce que c'est
ça bah c'est le fameux drones d'amazon
qui toujours dans leurs cartons et qui
promet de livraison de tout objet de
cinq livres ou moins dans un délai de 30
minutes à votre porte
mais ça ça veut dire qu'il ya encore
plus de pollution sonore pollution
visuelle dans le ciel alors on le voit
en définitive ces questions là elles
sont oui technologique mais aussi et
surtout politiques et celle va falloir
en discuter
oui et pourtant est-ce qu'on peut
arrêter le progrès oui effectivement
mais en bout du compte c'est une
question politique et engouement
quand même une prise là dessus très bien
merci beaucoup matesi ces lignes